do you think as some senior politicians  in britain seem to  that president biden is woke  i've i can't comment on that i i've i i  i  but what i know is that he's a fervent  believer in the transatlantic  alliance and um and  that's a great thing and a believer in a  lot of the things that  we want to achieve together and  you know insofar as um not wrong being  being woke if but i've what i can tell  you is that  uh i think that it's it's very very  important for  uh everybody uh to um  certainly i i will put myself in the  category of people who believe that  uh it's important to stick up for your  uh your history of your your  your traditions and uh thing and your uh  your values and things you believe in so  boris johnson's not quite  able to resist talking about cultural  war issues even in the context of joe  biden with whom he's got to build a  strong relationship cultural war  issues still dominating politics on both  sides of the atlantic